from epic battle scenes impenetrable
costumes and impossible stunts marvel
constantly has their fans jaws dropping
with 98 of the footage from the mcu
films being sent to the special effects
editing professionals it isn't hard to
imagine how different our favorite
avengers look behind the scenes but
imagining and seeing are two different
things from end game to wandavision and
peter parker in between you won't
believe how dramatically different these
marvel scenes look without the power of
vfx and cgi
just a
big chocolate missile how iconic was
this girl power moment in avengers
endgame however while it may have come
together seamlessly on screen the
arrival of the female avengers took a
bit more extra work behind the scenes as
you can see here each avenger had to be
added in almost one by one some of them
were included using special effects and
others just popped up from underneath
the camera's view
you got something for me
captain america's encounter with himself
while searching for the infinity stones
was already mind-boggling but watching
how they filmed the scene hurt our
brains even more chris evans filmed both
parts individually with his stunt double
swapping roles between takes the editors
did their magic later on to make it seem
as if it truly was a double trouble
situation
can do this all day yeah i know
although heartbreaking watching tony
stark's sacrifice again is worth it just
to see how it looked behind the scenes
there was actually no infinity glove no
battle raging around him and no thanos
looming over him just rdj's pure talent
this vision versus vision fight in
wandavision took a lot of work paul
bettany filmed this scene with his stunt
double and they later digitally enhanced
his stunt doubles face to look like paul
instead you can also see that the upper
part of vision suit as well as the
environment around them was added in
later with special effects
but i'm not the true vision
getting to see the true strength of
wanda's powers in wanda vision was epic
but the cast and crew weren't treated to
the same experience while elizabeth
olsen was filming without special
effects wanda's combustion in the west
view town square kinda looked a little
like an adult temper tantrum but it's
still impressive to think about how it
all came together in the end
this scene had our heart rates spiking
but we're glad to know tom holland
wasn't in any danger filming it behind
the scenes thanos ship was actually just
a green screen wall that tom holland was
climbing while attached to a wire and
wearing a motion capture suit we're too
high up you're running out of air
that makes sense the final battle was
much less anticlimactic behind the
scenes than on screen the majority of
the time the cast wasn't even on set
with one another at the same time the
day where the avengers charged was when
they had the most people on set and even
that pales in comparison to all the
digital enemies we saw in the final cut
if you look closely you'll see the
avenger army charged into a green screen
filming black widow and her motorcycle
was an event that included a harley bike
specifically created for the film stunt
doubles and motorcycle cameras for
close-up shots they would film scarlett
johansson at a standstill but for action
shocks they had her stunt double weaving
in and out of cars while two cameras
followed in front and behind on
motorcycles of their own
i'm always picking up after you boys
not all special effects are done with
vfx especially in the first episodes of
wandavision they swapped out wanda's red
waves of power for strings poles and
simple speed adjustments to achieve that
perfect 1950s style
well please eat before it gets cold
sorry to disappoint but thanos not real
not even behind the scenes in order to
bring him to life josh brolin had to
wear a big motion capture suit which
made his battle for the infinity
gauntlet with captain america in end
game a little awkward without all of the
special effects
captain america's shield was also added
with vfx meaning while filming it was
basically chris evans throwing an
imaginary weapon at josh brolin while he
pretended to get hit all six stones i
could simply snap my fingers
living on a land full of vibranium would
be epic but unfortunately wakanda was
all green screen and special effects
including their futuristic planes
however they still tried to make filming
as realistic as possible like the fight
scene between t'challa and umbaku where
the set designer created a pretty
realistic base for the shoot
glory to hanuman
dr strange's cape for a lot of the
scenes wasn't actually there benedict
cumberbatch would go through the motions
of grabbing and putting on the cape but
it was added in later on using special
effects they just couldn't recreate how
life-like it was without help from the
digital realm however in other scenes
where it wasn't the main focus it was
just a part of benedict's costume
mark ruffalo has expressed in the past
how embarrassing it sometimes was to be
dressed in a large motion capture suit
around the rest of the avengers cast
while we admit it looks a bit odd it was
also that the editing team could do
their magic like in this scene with the
hulk and the ancient one he's wearing
his suit but also standing on an
elevated surface in a green screen
studio instead of new york
and hulk
smash
it's obvious to see that the spider-man
illusion battle was completely done
using digital effects thanks to the
company frame store however how did they
get spider-man to move so much like tom
holland well they made sure that they
filmed the stunts and movements with tom
in a motion capture suit so that they'd
be able to add the extra realism to the
scene zendaya's part was also added into
the digital sequence later on
we saw plenty of different versions of
vision in wandavision however what we
didn't realize is that for a portion of
the series he was actually blue avatar
blue the showrunners worked with the
makeup department to find what color
paint would look the best translated in
black and white turns out blue looked
much better than maroon and they stuck
with the color through every black and
white scene he shot
humans are odd
valkyrie's entrance was intense but when
you take a peek behind the curtains the
intensity is deflated the horse she was
riding was actually just an animatronic
and the area around her was completely
green screen even wanda's magical drop
down was done with just elizabeth olsen
and a harness
as much as we wish these portals were
real those magic rings we see in doctor
strange are actually just shiny metal
circles with a green screen backdrop
they were elevated to give the effects
of the actors stepping in and did help
them meet their marks evidently adding a
little more realism to it all
hi everyone i hope you're enjoying this
phone
to get captain marvel in the air
involved a lot of vfx green screen and
major dedication from brie larson the
actress was attached to a contraption
made of poles that allowed the film crew
to rotate her and manipulate her in any
direction they needed this was all done
in front of a green screen so that her
powers location and even part of her
suit could be added in during
post-production it takes a lot to make a
superhero look fabulous
the spider-man cast didn't actually film
in london at least for this battle scene
and far from home the vfx team created a
digital london for the film while the
actors performed in a studio with
minimal props and structures compared to
what we see in the final cut
sorry to break the illusion but iron
man's suit wasn't actually physically
there the majority of the time
oftentimes rdj would just wear part of
the armor on top of a motion capture
suit there were other scenes where he
would wear a physically larger suit with
his helmet being the only part added
with vfx it really depended on what the
script required of him that day
is everything a joke to you
funny things
the marvel creators got to spend extra
time playing around with falcon for his
new series falcon and the winter soldier
and we aren't complaining they put in
the work researching and using footage
from skydivers in order to get the
perfect look for the falcons flying
scenes they seamlessly fit together raw
shots and digital creations to give us
these shots
getting chris evans to look a lot
smaller than he really was was a
challenge
the production team had to go through
multiple steps first the scene was
filmed with body double leander dini who
still had to diet for the role they then
digitally replaced his face with chris
evans in editing sometimes they would
even have to scale down the actor
compared to the environment depending on
the scene iron man wasn't the only one
with cool gadgets at his expense we got
to see happy's plane in spider-man far
from home and we were just as impressed
as peter parker however behind the
scenes the plane didn't really exist
while they did build part of the
interior as a set the majority was
created digitally
watching how they filmed the rocket
raccoon scenes is kind of unsettling
take a look rocket was of course created
digitally but in order to capture
realistic movements sean gunn the
director's brother acted out the scenes
in a motion capture suit because of the
animal-like movements he was able to
replicate
the vulture wasn't slick and fast which
means the spider-man filmmakers needed
to make sure the vulture's special
effects portrayed his heaviness
it required some research on how humans
look flying with jet packs so that they
could replicate it and then add in those
digitally created wings
[Music]
if you're not over how epic black widow
is raise your hand while there's no
doubt scarlett johansson brought natasha
romanov to life perfectly it couldn't
have been done without the added touch
of special effects so what exactly does
black widow's butt kicking and
motorcycle riding look like without the
help of cgi stunt doubles and vfx we'll
give you a hint drastically different
that's not up to you
what would an avengers film be without
an epic slow-mo walk sequence while this
end-game scene may seem straightforward
at first glance watching the
behind-the-scenes footage will tell you
otherwise the vfx team played a huge
role in the moment by adding in their
white time traveling suits while filming
all of the actors including scarlett
were wearing motion capture suits
instead the special effects team
actually helped out the costume
department with this one the design for
the costume wasn't complete yet so they
decided on adding it digitally
black widow's big face reveal while
acting as councilwoman holly had a shook
but it probably left you with a lot of
how questions scarlett along with
holly's actress jenny agata both filmed
this scene separately on a green screen
and then the rest was left to the
magical powers of vfx to sync and create
that transition can you give her a
lesson
if you can impress tony stark you know
you're doing something right scarlett
performed this entire fight scene with
happy herself it did take quite a few
weeks of training with her stunt double
heidi money maker but by the end of it
she was flipping john favreau on his
back like it was her job it kind of was
although heidi did admit there was a
part of the fight sequence that she had
to jump in and film herself the stunt
included a one-handed cartwheel that led
to her legs around his neck so that she
was able to push him to the ground and
flip him over
the truth is during this age of ultron
scene scarlett johansson was barely
present some shots were done using a
motorcycle rig and an enormous green
screen background others were
complimented with additional footage
that was added on with vfx later on and
captain america's shield without special
effects it was nothing more than a
tennis ball the coolest part about the
scene though might be the fact that
scarlett and her stunt double were made
custom motorcycles just for the marvel
films
stunt double heidi had to take over for
a lot of this epic hallway sequence in
iron man 2. however scarlett was
determined to film as much as possible
and trained for four hours a day for
eight weeks to be able to include parts
that were all her but it wasn't without
some hesitancy from the actress when i
first saw the sequence that they wanted
me to do and it was completed and
choreographed i just thought to myself
oh my god how am i gonna do this
to keep her safe she was attached to a
harness a lot of the time in the end
having her included in the scene added
even more realism to everything
the last five years i've been trying to
do one thing get to right here special
effects were helping out black widow
right until the very end her trip to
vormir with hawkeye might be one of the
most vfx heavy scenes she was a part of
this soulful adventure was filmed in
front of a large blue screen with the
cliff edge being a platform that was
constructed in the studio a harness and
wire were used for the final moment of
black widow's story excuse us while we
cry for a second
play it like some debris is coming down
you know what i mean like you know you
could feel the blast
this bucky car chase scene didn't look
anything like the extravagant final cut
we saw unfold on our screen bucky's
actor sebastian stan wasn't even present
for this part of the filming scarlett
and chris evans filmed at a standstill
in a studio car in front of a green
screen what makes the whole behind the
scenes moment even more lackluster is
that they also filmed without sound
effects they instead took directions on
where to look and where to shoot from
the director
the scene where widow takes on bucky
single-handedly is another moment that
looks completely different without the
marvel movie magic scarlett and
sebastian performed this scene
themselves but it wasn't without some
added safety and effects scarlett was
attached to a harness and a wire so that
she could keep her balance on
sebastian's shoulder and then safely get
pushed off like the car chase scene all
of the action and sound effects in the
final cut weren't present while they
were filming
payload's secure thanks sam don't thank
me
i'm not thinking that thing
despite her dedication to stunts and
fight training in the past this moment
was just a little too high caliber and
dangerous for scarlett to attempt this
means she was nowhere in sight for the
filming of this sequence it was shot
with stunt doubles all around according
to the filmmakers this helped the scene
turn out more realistic instead of
having to film multiple cuts with shots
of scarlet intertwined
well you pulled this off i remember a
time when that seemed pretty impossible
too
before black widow and hulk kindled
their little romance things were pretty
rough rough as in he chased her down
while destroying everything in his path
however for the filming of scenes like
this scarlett would film with a green
screen behind her oh thank god so they'd
be able to add the hulk in later
digitally the explosions we see in the
behind the scenes were controlled
pyrotechnics meant to imitate hulk's
destruction
remember the huge boat featured in the
opening scenes of winter soldier
completely vfx check out this wild
breakdown for filming scarlett chris and
the rest of the cast actually just shot
in a studio surrounded by a massive
green screen scarlett still came flying
in but she was all decked out in a
harness for safety and instead of
falling from a plane it was just from
her place a couple of feet in the air
i'm gonna get a view like this
we all know that marvel didn't actually
destroy new york city for this battle
but we also didn't expect it to be
filmed the way it was the moment that
included black widow was shot entirely
in studio with the actors surrounded by
a ginormous green screen the rubble of
new york was added in with vfx later
apart from a few props like the classic
new york taxis scarlett also had some
help from her son team to execute all of
the fight sequences she had
who here hasn't been to space
besides the actual actors there wasn't
much that was there during the filming
of black widow's first adventure to
space
and even then bradley cooper wasn't
sitting in the pilot seat in place of
his character rocket
rocket along with the entire spaceship
and captain marvel's suit were added in
using computerized special effects if
you look closely you can see the motion
capture dots that brie larson had to
wear in this scene
this earth-shattering or should we say
earth blipping battle in infinity war
was filmed on location but they needed
multiple blue screens to transform an
ordinary field into the battlegrounds we
saw in the final cut they even have blue
screen platforms to add dimension and
help the actors by adding some realism
to it all with black widow on the front
lines of the war she was in the midst of
all the special effects like the wakanda
shields that were non-existent behind
the scenes filming these moments took a
lot of imagination on the actors and
director's part
mark ruffalo hasn't been shy about how
embarrassed he was to have to wear a
full motion capture suit while filming
amongst the other avengers i've seen
worse but during this brainstorming sesh
it definitely helped out scarlett having
mark act out the scene instead of just
digitally adding in hulk afterward
allowed scarlett to carry out a proper
conversation instead of her having to
rely on imagination
far from home wouldn't be the same movie
without its incredible special effects
everything from touching up spidey's
suits to creating the elementals
required multiple companies hundreds of
people and hours of work so we'll spend
this video breaking down their additions
to the film and just how incomplete it
would look without them in every
interview when i wear the bubble hat and
i'm like
no you didn't
far from home's most memorable scene has
got to be the intense illusion battle
the big midway fight sequence of the
film frame store the company in charge
of the sequence was given an unusual
amount of freedom to create the scene
they weren't given a set script to
follow instead they were given the
creative freedom to come up with the
concepts for the illusions at the same
time they were animating and adding
effects to the shots this gave them the
unique opportunity to provide direction
for the on-set production team for
example with this shot where mj is
attacked by mysterio framestore blocked
out the animation ahead of time with a
cgmj complete with precise lighting from
the moon and lights of the eiffel tower
this rendered footage was passed along
to the set production who were able to
recreate the exact lighting frame store
needed for the shot this allowed them to
slip zendaya's performance into the
final product looking absolutely perfect
by the way the construction site where
the battle takes place
100
cg
frame store created the entire building
model adding tom holland's mocap footage
on top they used a mocap suit instead of
filming tom in costume to save time on
set all of those reality bending
illusions would have meant way too many
costume changes for just one sequence
that nightmare inducing zombie iron man
utilized mocap as well frame store went
through several designs for the undead
hero finding the right balance to be
horrifying without showing anything too
gruesome the final product finds a good
middle ground resembling a mummy beneath
the broken bits of machinery
marvel movie goers are no stranger to
the incredible holograms of this
cinematic universe which means the vfx
teams have to keep their designs
consistent with the marvel style while
putting in a few new twists to keep the
visuals from getting stale for long time
fans for this scene where mysterio was
introduced as quentin beck and explains
the elemental attacks filming was done
using a special lightbox table rising
sun pictures had to not only design and
place the holograms in the scene but
adjust the lighting and colors depending
on which holograms were showing to make
them look like they were really in the
room with the actors the work had to be
done in layers sometimes completely
removing the lighting from on set
the lighting in the raw footage lacks
the subtle colors reflecting from the
holograms that don't just make the scene
look pretty but create an atmosphere to
complement the actors performances
sometimes an actor's job boils down to
fighting invisible monsters on set the
scene with the water elemental battle
was filmed on set with recreations of
buildings from venice on top of a huge
pool of water and blue screens as
backdrops while the scene utilized a ton
of cg most of the stunts were
accomplished by tom and his stunt
doubles luke scott and greg townley i
never have a start level it's always me
vfx not only hid the wires required to
help tom jump from pole to pole and volt
onto the rialto bridge but filled in the
backgrounds of venice and of course
brought the water elemental to life
there were no rigs or dummies used for
the monster which means the actors had
to rely on their imaginations to really
sell their performances all of that
water they were drenched with was real
though and very cold
similar techniques were used for filming
the scenes in london while portions of
the scenes set on tower bridge were
filmed on location they also filmed
using set pieces such as the tour bus in
front of green screens the shots
littered with rubble and broken down
cars were set pieces in front of green
screens too for wide shots imageworks
built a complete 3d model of tower
bridge this model was also used for
filming all the destruction that took
place during the climactic final battle
during all this action we see tons of
drones in various states of despair
imageworks was able to create all of
these broken bots by altering their
original models the drones were
constructed out of various individual
pieces all coming together to form a
single machine
like the water elemental the drones
didn't use any objects on set as
stand-ins to help the actors visualize
the scene here's what peter's final
confrontation with beck really looked
like on set
believe it or not this scene set in a
vibrant field of tulips was filmed in an
empty grassland in the uk the jet and
all the flowers were cg
image engine had to simulate an entire
field of tulips with natural wind as
well as the jet landing over two million
tulips were simulated in this scene
there were eight colors and eight
different tulips created for each color
in order to render all of them
efficiently they used a method called
precaching where software will download
data ahead of time in anticipation of
its use that way the computers weren't
forced to simulate two million flowers
at the same time stripped of cgi this
scene is just tom holland and john
favreau standing in some grass
did you know imageworks did vfx for all
the previous spider-man movies that's
right they provided effects for the
original trilogy and the amazing
spider-man producers were actually
reluctant to go to them again for the
mcu installments since they wanted to
give the third iteration of the hero a
fresh new look that was until they saw
this test footage imageworks whipped up
to prove that they were up to the task
that's not tom holland in costume that's
completely cg the 3d model looked and
moved so convincingly that even tom
holland himself was fooled to innovate
on their previous work they focused on
making mcu's spider-man the most
realistic one yet they did this by
studying imperfections in tom's
movements from unused takes and
incorporating them into the animated
spider-man moments of hesitation or
getting caught off balance helped make
the cg spidey feel far more grounded in
reality than any of the previous films
while some of spidey's suits are
completely computer generated and
require a mocap suit even the costumes
on set require digital tweaking here and
there it can be as simple as removing
wrinkles to keep the suit looking smooth
or adding wear and tear from the intense
action sequences
following in tony stark's footsteps
peter enters the workshop in the back of
the jet to build his own suit for the
first time since he ran around queens in
sweats while the shots of peter entering
are all cg there was also a physical set
for the workshop after filming tom on
set the holograms were added in post
with vfx image engine had to create an
exact replica of the set in order to
accurately layer the holograms and
moving machinery over the real footage
bringing the workshop to life in the
final product this scene isn't just an
important character moment for peter but
a chance for the audience to see what
goes into building a stark tech spidey
suit image engine had to decide what the
individual elements of the suit would
look like ultimately breaking it down
into three layers for the construction
process there is a white wet fiber layer
a layer of black and red fabric
detailing and a layer for hard surfaces
such as the eyepieces and chest patches
the company in charge of vfx for the
final battle in london imageworks kept
these details consistent when adding
battle damage to the suit if we look at
his suit closely during his emotional
reunion with mj we can see patches of
white material where the suit sustained
damage
behind the cgi of venom there are stunts
practical effects and a ton of
impressive acting
venom is a really visually exciting
movie to watch especially because of the
wild and shocking transformation we see
eddie undergo the complex villain is
brought to life thanks to some truly
remarkable cgi
behind the scenes is just as
action-packed as the final cut of these
films
venom 2 definitely doesn't hold back on
the wild action and impressive cgi work
these tendrils have a total life of
their own in this shot but behind the
scenes the carnage arm grab looks pretty
different
instead of real tendrils wires and
harnesses did the heavy lifting to make
sure the cameras captured what they
needed
the restricted spin around while being
held by wires looks far from comfortable
to deal with but it was well worth it
considering just how epic the final
result looks
while tom hardy gives a great
performance the shape-shifting
transformation we see on screen from man
to super villain is all thanks to
painstakingly detailed cgi work
the vfx team actually created animations
for every single frame we see
while it took a lot of time and
expertise it was the best way to make
sure the transformation looked as slick
and real as it does
every layer of the detailed animation
images contributes to making venom's
interactions with people and the world
looks so convincing
one of the coolest scenes in the first
venom takes to the streets with this
massive mess of black tendrils moving
from flat on the ground to a powerful
stance
while his movements look flawless in the
final cut behind the scenes was a very
different story as the actors were hard
at work to perfect choreography to
properly map out the movements the cgi
team needed the best footage to work
with to bring venom to the screen in
such a central and powerful way
in the end they definitely were not
disappointed
the second venom film features a pretty
massive leap onto the hood of a car
that's made to look like an effortless
motion in post-production but as we can
see behind the scenes a lot of prep had
to be done and safety measures had to be
considered for this superhuman moment
seeing just how intense the stunt is
without cgi is a great example of how
much acting the performers need to do to
appear as though these daunting tasks
are totally effortless
venom let there be carnage is filled
with plenty of shooting scenes which of
course are no match for the creature the
drama of it all is still as present
without cgi considering the high stakes
and loud noises
all the flashes of light and details to
support the storytelling are courtesy of
added effects since they were just
shooting blanks on the set
the living room sequence in the first
venom film is one of the most intense
battles in part because of the power
imbalance one versus three hardly seems
fair except for when the one actually
turns out to be pretty fine on his own
thanks to the power of venom the cgi in
this scene is key for showing the
surprising and powerful transformation
tom hardy goes through a whole lot of
stage combat and practical effects
contributed to executing the battle so
well
as he slowly discovers the sheer amount
of power he has tom hardy looks a bit
crazy staring down at his fist as if it
were a monster
and to be fair with the cgi monstrous is
a pretty good descriptor for what we end
up seeing
part of what makes the cgi so effective
is the fact that hardy performed each of
these scenes with 100 commitment
especially when he was embodying venom
the motorcycle chase scene is one of the
most complicated sequences shot for the
first film and an epic point of action
while the scene itself only lasts a few
minutes before filming even commenced
planning happened for months to make
sure it could all be carried out
efficiently while making sure the epic
footage was still captured what's even
crazier is that the whole chase was
actually filmed and cgi was what managed
to weave the whole scene together
seamlessly and with impressive detail no
less
stunt doubles took over for the actual
riding on the streets robbie madison and
joe dryden performed legendary motorbike
stunts considering all the planning it's
no surprise about 40 cars ended up being
used and inevitably destroyed over the
course of filming while cgi did amp up
the look of this nosedive through flames
stunt performer dryden really did whip
through fire to make sure the team had
the best shot they could get to be
perfected of course with special effects
we get to see the venom tendrils in full
force when they bring hardy's character
to safety well as safe as someone can be
whipping through the city on a
motorcycle
filming in studio saw the actor
maneuvered by a harness to move from
floating in the air to regaining control
but the moment cgi came into play was
when the scene really came to life
robbie madison looked danger straight in
the face when he was preparing for the
huge jump on the famously steep bullet
hill this was actually the performer's
very first jump in america and was it
ever a cool one
since the team was limited in how many
times the stunt could be performed they
needed cgi to make sure the scene looked
good in the movie after three stunt
jumps madison was able to really hear
the sounds of the cars crashing and the
intensity of the whole experience hit
him the effects added in post made the
jump look even more legendary
for the wicked motorcycle sandwich the
performers were in real cars and hardy
was actually on top of a motorcycle but
the whole scene was filmed while the
vehicles were stationary filming with a
blue screen behind them hardy had some
good opportunities to really perform
well on the motorbike and all the while
not having to worry about his own safety
the cgi fills in the blank adding the
scenery and effects to amplify the
intensity of this moment
this motorcycle slide is nothing short
of impressive the two weeks spent to
create a specially designed metal plate
for the motorcycle to attach to in order
to safely whip around with such speed
was well worth the effort the experience
of filming was pretty wild and the final
result adds a really cool unexpected
moment to the whole sequence
the visual details of venom really
complete the masterpiece
this apartment fight was pretty wicked
and included the vicious weight throwing
move
luckily the actors weren't in any actual
dangers since there weren't any real
weights on the set cgi isn't just used
for big explosions and out of this world
creatures sometimes generating images
for more typical or practical effects is
what's needed
with major throws come a whole lot of
wires and harnesses
while in the first movie we see exactly
what outer force throws him around
behind the scenes it almost looks a bit
more like magic since hardy was hooked
up to wires and harnesses making sure
the tricky stunts could be filmed safely
it looks incredible in rehearsal so it's
no surprise that the final product is a
gem as well slamming into the wall over
and over again can't have been the most
comfortable experience for the actor
though
there were a fair number of window jumps
in the first venom film some simple
leaps from inside a corridor shattering
glass in the midst and in other cases
epic leaps through the air in both cases
cgi played a key role filling in the
scenery and making performers look like
they're really soaring
especially when it came to all the venom
detailing
one more one more one more one more
still wrong ready 25 million per episode
and over 2
496 shots with visual effects in the
series how did wandavision do it the
series shows an array of genres from
varied decades to drama to total
slapstick comedy so what did that mean
behind the scenes what were the secrets
behind the magic
we'll be covering how the production
brought magic to the screen and what it
was really like for the performers
experiencing it it's been really fun
and different however if you haven't
watched the whole series yet approach
with caution
yes yes avengers end game had
2496 shots with visual effects and paul
bettany aka vision has confirmed that
one division had even more how is this
even possible considering how extensive
the effects are for the action-packed
film
well the movie runs just over three
hours whereas the total running time of
all the one division episodes is a bit
over five and a half hours not to
mention multiple decades and this
fantastic transformation from a
grayscale world to color at the end of
the day a greater variety and amount of
vfx were needed to suit the vision of
the show we should also mention that
there were a whopping 10 different
effects companies that contributed to
one division five and a half hours of
content 10 vfx companies and about
225 million dollars spent on the entire
series
yeah we can see how over 2500 vfx shots
make sense i'll give you the role you
chose
as the series continued we got to see
more and more of the marvel magic that
we're used to and they didn't shy away
from it when wanda was in the town
square surrounded by the town's people
of westview watching this scene without
all the effects and wanda's red power
blasting through the hex is definitely
different but the sheer scale of it all
is still really impressive then of
course we all got to revel in the power
of the scarlet witch
naturally they couldn't really have
glowing red surrounding her entirely but
this green screen did the trick
olson's delicate and powerful hand
motions really do their job in making
this magic look real add the glowing
eyes and she is set
olson is no stranger to wire work and
thank goodness because she had plenty of
it in one division she looks so calm
cool and collected as she descends down
into the square here i don't understand
this power
and how about those epic battle scenes
olson said that this may actually be the
first time marvel had a full battle
sequence taking place entirely in the
air
take note of how many wires there are
all over these shots the rigging is
definitely no small task
thank goodness cgi is able to edit out
all the tricks of the trade used to make
the magic though not everything needed a
highly technical vfx
adding some of this magic was as simple
as well
cue the giant fans for agatha it may
have been her first time in the mcu and
defying gravity but she looks like she's
totally in her element here as we can
see she wasn't holding back one bit and
seemed to really revel in the magic of
it all how about these tense moments
where the actors appeared to simply be
levitating without all the wild movement
and soaring through the air
well as we can see here olsen was
essentially placed in a concoction of
wires to hold her up and floating in
agatha's chamber it doesn't look too
comfortable but the final result well it
speaks for itself let's let agnes give
it a try
for a human playing a synthesoid betany
does an incredible job as vision however
credit has to be given to the vfx team
who did an incredible job at using cgi
for his face as well yes he spends hours
in the makeup chair and gets a whole lot
of prosthetics done but to really bring
the vision of vision to life a team
effort is needed the acting emotion and
heart that's all betany but his face is
often cgied and augmented with effects
his ears are really the main part cgi'd
out of the shot as we can see here
notice how detailed each layer that is
added is
each line on his head every ridge and
texture is added to really perfect the
look let's also take a minute to
acknowledge how flawlessly he moves when
he's flying
have you ever seen a more graceful sweep
and then of course we all got to
experience double vision
not too shabby
i wish to understand it
tiana paris actually had no idea that
she was auditioning to play monica rambo
and when she found out well let's just
say she was thrilled
so thrilled she even nearly tested her
superpowers on the spot practically
tried to jump off a set of stairs
because i thought i could fly i was so
excited luckily she waited until she was
on set to try to find gravity
though flying isn't nearly as impressive
as what her character actually went
through remember when wanda blasted her
out of the hex
well fortunately paris didn't have to
bear the brunt of wanda's upset
instead it was a three-dimensional
figure based on pairs that was computer
generated and then added to the shots
and after
vfx though the intense rejection wasn't
quite enough to keep her out of the hex
and mesmerized us with the incredible
transition through static and memory
what were those digital graphics
inspired by exactly anyway
not to worry we'll be getting to that
the hex is probably one of the most
powerful forces we've ever seen at play
in the mcu
we were majorly impressed by the fact
that the team managed to augment the
invisible barriers so intricately this
of course took loads of cgi
the main idea behind the visuals of the
hex was fairly obvious for the team
television what else could suit the show
better
the waves and graphics that we see used
here reflect what magnetization looked
like across the screen what pixelation
looked like when super zoomed into
old-fashioned tvs as well as the thin
lines often seen on those old tvs
it was all a reflection of the evolution
of television technology
everything might look fake in the tv but
everything in there is real turning the
sword base into a circus well
let's just call it a very apt metaphor
check out what this setting looked like
before and after the cgi
accomplishing this transformation
actually wasn't too difficult according
to the vfx specialists it was as simple
as filming both settings and then using
cgi to augment each one
one of the best complements of vfx or
cgi person can receive is that people
had no idea that some of what's seen on
screen is actually created by computers
one of the more subtle and surprising
cgi touches was the stage found in the
town square
at first glance we thought this
gazebo-like building was the same one
used by wanda and vision when they
perform in the talent show but seeing
the slightly different looking structure
in this later episode we realize it's
not any type of building at all but a
blue screen this is one of those
instances where we really had to see it
to believe it a very small detail but it
proves to us just how much magic there
is who knew this seemingly simple frame
would be one of the over 2500 with added
effects
no abracadabra
it wasn't all too serious on set though
the cast definitely had their fair share
of fun
especially with so many key players like
tayana paris deborah joe rupp and
catherine han joining the mcu for the
very first time
we just love how enthusiastic rupp was
about having her body scan done for cgi
honestly we'd probably be just as
excited han was enjoying herself so much
that she even made some entrances way
earlier than she needed to it's okay
though we wanted all the agatha we could
get
but it wasn't just the newbies who had a
wild time olsen herself started to push
it in the episode that she goes through
an entire pregnancy in a day and went a
bit too over the top
granted wanda's hormones were going wild
at that point
or maybe it had something to do with
that wig
here we are behind the scenes
with loki there's no denying the
magnetic appeal of loki tom hiddleston's
incredible performance gets most of the
credit but even he needs help bringing
the trickster god to life on film to
celebrate loki getting his very own
series we're giving you a look at some
behind the scenes magic of how marvel
brings the god of mischief to the screen
in all his glory loki is still working
on that i think for this scene from thor
the dark world the first thing they
filmed was tom hiddleston doing an
impression of captain america as loki
complete with cap's costume there wasn't
a technical reason for this apparently
tom just really wanted to wear the
costume it's not going to be you though
we're going to get chris to shoot it
when he's on set and we're going to he
said no no this is my one chance to wear
a captain america suit later evans was
shown the footage and did his best to
mimic tom's performance replacing it in
the final product he it's him doing an
impression of me doing an impression of
him
and it's brilliant
a good villain needs a grand entrance
and loki certainly doesn't disappoint
loki's entrance in the first avengers
movie is a memorable one thanks in no
small part to the vfx team even without
the final polish and the wires still in
sight this shot of tom performing this
stunt is just as impressive as the
finished shot from the movie where loki
leaps through the air and takes down a
shield agent always
try and enjoy myself to be having the
best time
speaking of dramatic entrances this
scene from the first episode of loki
where he's being processed by the tva
was achieved with a real trapdoor and
tom hiddleston on wires he was hooked up
to a rig to achieve a controlled drop
ensuring his safety as they filmed the
stunt luckily tom already has a lot of
experience doing wire work since loki
always seems to be getting tossed around
just me jumping into trenches in the set
creating that iconic scene where loki
gets hulk smashed was tricky you can't
exactly do that with stunt work to pull
this off tom had a wire attached to his
ankle with a mat on the floor to catch
him
and three of the strongest stunt guys
holding the wire at the other end they
waited to interrupt his villainous
monologue and yanked hard pulling tom
out of frame and down onto the mat the
rest was done with hard work from the
special effects department the
experience of being yanked out of frame
was one i will not forget in a hurry
loki and thor's banter in this scene
from thor the dark world where they
break out of asgard is unforgettable as
well as a brilliant mix of practical and
special effects chris and tom filmed
this scene on a set of the ship's
interior with special effects creating
the holographic interfaces and adjusting
the lighting accordingly while thor
practically throws loki out the door
chris gives tom a light shove who then
has to throw himself out of the door
onto a mat below i mentioned i love my
scenes with chris in every film there's
a two-hander where we kind of touch on
this
odin's emotional departure in thor
ragnarok took place on a beautiful
scenic cliffside that doesn't actually
exist these scenes were filmed in a
grassy field with the future locations
of new asgard being entirely built
around them using cgi another surprising
use of digital effects in this scene is
odin's eye patch which was changed in
post from the plain black eye patch
anthony hopkins wore while filming yeah
that easy
well it's a trick dramatic entrances
probably run in the family because as
soon as hella arrives on the scene you
know she means business thor and loki
immediately know she's going to be
trouble and suit up to get this magical
costume change chris and tom were filmed
entering in both costumes the footage
was spliced together and the effects
team created thor's lightning and loki's
signature green shimmer of magic to
create a transition between these
changes putting them together for one
seamless shot look he was a bad guy
well lucky was a misunderstood guy we
love seeing the odin sons work together
like when they teamed up in the dark
world using loki's illusion magic they
fooled malekith into believing loki had
betrayed thor going as far as pretending
to cut off thor's hand and give up jane
foster it's very accurate in this shot
loki literally kicks thor while he's
down sending him rolling on set it was
hiddleston delivering a kick that didn't
connect and hemsworth was pulled away
using wires
never was torturous at all so i'm
incredibly proud of this while there
were parts of thor and loki's
confrontation with malekith that were
filmed on location in iceland taking
advantage of some barren volcanic
landscapes the more effects heavy shots
were filmed on a green screen set this
behind-the-scenes footage really gives
you an appreciation for the amount of
faith actors have to put into their
directors and their special effects team
there's an art to the physicality of
performances with invisible elements
like cgi magic and tom pulls it off
beautifully while it may look silly on
set the final product was anything but
it can be surprising exactly which
elements of a scene are created using
cgi like loki's chains in the avengers
yeah for whatever reason those were cgi
not part of tom's costume like they were
for thor the dark world loki's
restraints and muzzle add a lot of
context to these shots so the behind the
scenes footage of the closing scene
looks pretty different without them
props to tom for being able to
convincingly move like someone in chains
even limiting how much he moved his
mouth and jaw i think well there was
always going to be an unanswered
question of what on earth happened
getting hulk smashed became an odinson
tradition in thor ragnarok when thor
faced off against hulk in the arena loki
clearly still holding on to some baggage
from his fight with hulk is thrilled to
see thor get the same treatment of
course tom didn't actually have a
spectacular fight to react to you would
never guess that the only thing he's
really looking at is a room full of
cameras and crew
in the first avengers movie thanos uses
one of his followers referred to as the
other to keep an eye on loki and monitor
his progress conquering earth the final
cut only kept one of their conversations
in with some horrific implications that
loki was being threatened with torture
but there were several more exchanges
between the two that got left out these
deleted scenes are unfinished but give
us an idea of what the raw filming
process looked like while the other
himself was achieved with practical
effects played by alexis denisof in
sculpts and makeup the alien world he
hangs out in when speaking to loki was
mostly blue screen
they followed me into
some interesting corners in the first
thor movie we meet the frost giants and
later learned that loki was originally
the son of their king not odin most of
the frost giants or yotens as they're
also called were filmed using practical
effects the actors would spend hours
having sculpts and makeup applied to
them to achieve just the right look but
this lengthy process wouldn't have been
practical for tom's brief scenes in
loki's yotan skin instead his red eyes
and blue skin were added in post as soon
as i look in the mirror after i've been
through it's like wow ever wonder why
loki's helmet has changed so many times
since the first thor movie even putting
on the helmet was more complicated than
you think since tom couldn't just pull
it on over his head the final product
used in thor actually had to come apart
in two pieces which would be snapped
together to encase tom's head according
to him it was like having his brain
cooked all of his body heat would build
up under the helmet driving him a bit
mad which he says he used to fuel his
performance that's probably why we see a
lot less of it in the avengers and it
didn't return until thor ragnarok with a
more minimalist redesign you have to be
careful what you're letting
in because you can that can sort of
spill into what you're doing last but
not least is this deleted scene from
thor it's a fun character moment where
loki gets to cause some mischief after
being mocked and laughed at loki gets
even by turning a goblet of wine into
snakes the effects are unfinished and
there's even some shots where lighting
rigs are still visible
props to this extra who had to
convincingly react to a magical prank
that wasn't actually happening you just
look at it as creatives and say look at
all of these things we can play with
when you're working on movies as crazy
as venom and its recent sequel of course
you're dealing with a whole lot of cgi
but did you know there are tricks to
making it look so sexy and smooth
let's take a look behind the vfx curtain
at let there be carnage
why do i even talk to you guys
everywhere else that story kills that's
the whole story yes
now that tom hardy's eddie brock and the
symbiote are more in sync and working as
venom this film freed up tom hardy to
really go nuts new director andy circus
wanted to give the actor the freedom to
move around without having to worry
about putting a man in a suit be it
mocap or monster on screen since venom
is coming out of hardy it made more
sense to have him skip the mocap and
layer the monstrous side of venom right
over the actor according to circus i've
spent a considerable amount of my life
playing a character with two sides to
his personality i knew that this film
would be about how to free up tom to
imagine venom's presence we knew it
would not be helpful for him to act
opposite a man in a suit because venom
is a symbiote coming out of him
we wanted to give tom the freedom in his
process to give the performance he
wanted hardy has also weighed in on this
decision saying in an interview for
total film that the decision to not
worry about mocap was an easy one given
the difference in height between himself
and venom as well as the extreme
flexibility of the creature's face and
limbs saying so the mo-cap treatment
went out the window pretty quickly
facially your eyes and teeth and tongue
are not going to match with this and you
need a seven foot tall basketball player
in a lycra suit for the physical shots
how do we you know
move this around not just necessarily
with uh
animation or cgi or motion capture but
as an actor
[Music]
you've got to be willing to look a
little nuts when you're pretending to be
a seven foot tall monster who eats
people's heads since the production
chose to have hardy physically on set
and doing stunt work for many of the
film's action sequences the actor had to
dig deep into his history of playing
tufts and heavies as well as his more
reactive animalistic performances like
max rokatanski in mad max fury road and
james cazaya delaney in taboo
just in case you know it's successful
which you hope it is and you put
everything into it
one of the biggest changes going into
venom 2 was the decision to replace
departing director ruben fleisher with
andy circus having made a name for
himself working with wetta to bring
characters like gollum king kong and the
planet of the apes is caesar to life
the guy is still the undisputed king of
detailed motion capture performances
even though the film shies away from
motion capture he was still an excellent
voice to have on set as he could help to
block out scenes and accommodate for the
height differences between his actors
and the creatures they were portraying
in fact circus received a call to
consult on the film though he didn't
know it at the time tom hardy gave
circus a call and said andy i'm going to
be doing this character and it's going
to be a digital character and i wondered
if i could come down to the imaginarium
which is a performance capture studio in
the uk but then circus didn't hear from
him again for a while and it wasn't
until venom came out that he realized
hardy was talking about venom he really
had to act in this movie he really is a
big character
one of the wildest things about watching
the new venom is checking out woody
harrelson as cletus cassidy as cassidy
harrelson is taking huge wild swings to
portray the serial killer imbuing him
with a larger than life personality as
he tears his way through san francisco
surfs on cars and generally looks like
he's having a blast the whole time i
just didn't feel like i was free enough
to be more creative
here's an incredible bit of stunt work
for you that motorcycle stunt where
eddie goes flying during a massive jump
well it turns out that it was really
mostly him the production set up the
jump and then put both the bike and
hardy on wires moving them together and
apart on a green screen and then adding
the cgi tendrils later
windows get smashed and motorbikes and
all kinds of things that happen
[Music]
one of the things that the sequel really
amps up from the first film is the
incredible dysfunctional domestic
relationship between eddie and the
symbiote treating them more like an old
married couple than a crime-fighting duo
this is on full glorious display during
the scenes set in eddie's apartment
where the effects team connected props
furniture and sometimes whole actors to
cables so that the objects were moving
through a physical space and could be
embellished with venom's many cgi
tendrils later on and yes that includes
sunny and cher eddie and venom's pet
chickens who were played by live animals
there's an enormous amount of humor to
be had out of this entire scene
here's something that's sure to give you
flashbacks to playing racing games when
you were little apparently tom hardy has
a habit on set of making his own sound
effects when he was getting hit or
throwing punches and even as he was
getting his nose broken by the symbiote
something that puts him in the grand
tradition of actors who can't stop
making sounds on set like harrison ford
in the original star wars i take orders
from just one person me
sometimes there's not a whole lot to do
but fake an entire scene such as this
one where cletus cassidy transforms
fully into carnage background locations
props the monster even cassidy himself
were all rendered digitally giving us a
cool and gnarly look at the musculature
of a symbiote suit when it puts itself
together
[Music]
sometimes fate and timing are against
you and you have to make certain
concessions to the movie gods for
example this scene with cassidy in the
car was originally supposed to be filmed
as a larger stunt on location except
well a little movie called the matrix
resurrections was shooting in town at
the same time and they got the location
first instead the scene with the
suspended car was rigged against blue
screens and large projection screens to
recreate the city skyline you know
that's cool because
i i sure enjoyed playing them and i'm
glad i got to do this
there seems to be one little trick to
shooting an animation scene in a venom
movie all you do is attach a string or a
suspension harness to literally
everything in the shot and then you pull
and wiggle everything around like these
poor stunt guys in the scene where
carnage and cassidy escape from prison
as i walked around i felt like the king
of course it wouldn't be a movie
released in 2021 if we didn't talk about
a little bit of pandemic delay shooting
on the film finished early on but due to
release delays andy circus and his team
were blessed with a ton of extra time to
tweak the edit of the film and more
closely oversee the cgi work
it takes a lot to create truly
convincing cgi back in the days of black
and white films production designers had
to work carefully to pick outlandish
colors that would still pop together and
to be distinguishable when reduced to a
grayscale but venom 2 is a testament to
the fact you still need to be careful to
create the illusion of this symbiote goo
actually coming out of the actors and
seeping through their clothes picking
placement and really reactive colors was
a must
finally here's a little bit of revenge
for you there are several large night
scenes in venom 2 where there are a
bunch of helicopters flying around in
the background they don't really impact
anything but they add a certain scope to
the scene so you might be forgiven for
thinking that they're cgi not true
though
they're actually helicopters that were
flying around a nearby location for the
shoot of
you guessed it the matrix resurrections
sweet free helicopters a film of this
scale this piece of grand entertainment
blockbuster material with a
predominantly black cast i mean it just
hasn't been done before say what you
want about tom hardy it takes a lot of
talent to be able to play off an
invisible alien that lives inside of you